hello and welcome to this video playing
Tim Wakefield yeah I had a game against
earlier with the commence gambit
accepted to wear spaulder position with
a simple extra porn so I'm going back to
Adam so here and see how he fares in
this opening and place the main line
let's see III here it's not very common
of course player I mean not not a barrel
I was always thinking that evil is a bit
a bit more critical but of course m3 is
not bad I was thinking a little bit
about castling here because sometimes
you can also delay that and claim that
that I let the claim is wrong but um lay
that on account of white maybe castling
long sometimes this is really happening
I can normally there will be three now
in this type of position to prevent the
faux Queen chachere's yep he did that
and I'm going to try to open up him
you
Bishop d3 94 is a mainline Bishop them
that is brit's pretty uncommon I think
because of d5 hmm so it doesn't mind
that d 4 is some is wrecking his pawn
structure maybe he's right maybe he's
right but it's pretty tough decision
they couldn't take because he too was
hanging so i can take III now yeah I
think I will so let's let's see a couple
of interesting options naija form just
attacking this okay keep it keep it
simple
and positive colored bishops but that's
not a draw anything like that em what
draw ish or something like that let's
just go back the bishop OMB tool doesn't
look very good and I know that this
looks a bit strange but it's I think
it's more important here to kill off
that bishop on the truth then worrying
about the light squares light squares
are not are not a huge factor here night
on f5 I can take and something coming to
g6 sign an idea is Quincy five and
possibly doing a form so I'm doing this
but surprised about Quincy to
the big passive that move miniqueen only
for wasn't doing that much but yeah now
is make a for I can play the thing is
I'm not sure how how much it Nets me
okay probably some kind of better end
game type of position but
okay so this one yeah I've takes you
four of course it's the kind of moment
where you're happy that you don't have
any smart move stuff like that activated
okay do I want to be five here i also
have a potential and let's do this
regrouping of the night a seven to be
five so be five I gunite 85 anyway so
don't mind that 95 94 ok my move socket
sloppy the pure procedure of making them
I mean okay um should I have avoided dad
maybe I should have home I mean okay
it's not a big issue I hope that wanting
to take 55 I mean I can go here and just
just down let's say provoca form
yeah Jack let's go for the pawns seems
really dangerous fairly dangerous as bit
of a euphemism it's probably winning for
black unless I'm screwing it up which of
course is one of my talents I might have
a look-see five that's kind of
unnecessary I mean I can I have some I
can spend some time yen to improve the
position of it before I'm doing
something drastic and drastic being be
too ok I can actually do that I was for
a moment i was thinking whoopsie five
but it's not not a big deal anyway so
now go be true
look see two maybe he said an idea check
but it should be a pretty
straightforward and the fair him timing
okay to was pretty cool white resign
that's a bit much I think he could have
defended this a bit better I was
thinking why didn't he take a for that
looks kind of normal looks like a
tougher defense and then that before
yeah the whole structure is kind of
comfortable for black of course check
yeah I think he has to take and play
this position I will probably win c4 and
a four but the drawing chances are a
higher here than I think in them in the
games the game setup you can only argue
about the yeah what what what check and
technical way is best but I was just
taking my time I mean I don't think he
has anything that he can do now i'm
happy i think that was a good technical
display and in the opening in the
opening here one issue is that this
whole line with III d 5 or d5 III and
then he capturing on c6 there are two
versions of that there is one version
with the porn on h6 wear white had
played Bishop g5 and Bishop t2 that was
what had happened in the game and there
is a version of the pony
seven and there is a difference actually
because after Bishop d3 in the version
with the porn back here I cannot go d5
as c takes Knight takes losses upon
which is not happening here that means
that Bishop d3 d5 is possible and
actually pretty much equalizing the game
as white doesn't have anything better
than something like that we're like it's
some happily developing you know I mean
something like this and this is no
problem net blacks um development is
good and the move f6 will effectively um
stop this bishop from being a dangerous
force in this game so black is okay here
and you went here d5 and now we allow to
euphoria and i don't know i think this
structure should be fine what white can
of course I'm avoid the capture him play
Quincy 3m move like that yeah I think
it's probably equal ish something
nothing and particularly special for any
side this is I'm liking I'm kind of
surprised that the computer is giving
this move I thought I would just win
stuff but it's got this the creatures
protected okay so the engine is coming
up with this one and incest equal
compensation okay now with before we
played f6 and then yeah being stunned
that it isn't any good okay yeah we
looked at the later stages of the game
already thanks for watching